hello and welcome I'm Melinda crane in
Berlin and on our agenda today
surveillance in a multitude of forms
starting with the latest revelations on
the NSA and it's very wide data
collection net how's the u.s.
definitively overstepped the balance
between freedom and security it's time
to talk who needs enemies when you've
got a friend who's bugging your offices
and embassies and screening up to half a
billion of your citizens phone calls
text messages and emails every month
that's what many people here in Germany
were asking after the whistleblower
Edward Snowden revealed that US
surveillance of its EU allies goes far
beyond what anyone supposed meanwhile
the EU satisfied that hungary has not
gone too far in curtailing freedom the
Council of Europe has decided not to put
hungry on a list of countries that it
monitors for adherence to the rule of
law despite a series of measures
restricting media and the courts but has
europe backed off too soon and finally a
surveillance tool with a bad rap is it
time to stop bashing drones a German
program to develop military drones has
been generating a lot of anger given
that it cost hundreds of millions and
proved a dismal failure well at a team
of computer scientists here in Berlin
say it's time to look on the bright side
flying robots could improve civilian
life in a myriad of ways and I want to
pick up on all of those topics now with
our guests here on their agenda and I'm
very pleased to introduce them our first
guest is Raul Rojas he's a professor of
computer science and mathematics at
Berlin's free university and a
specialist in robotics and our second
guest is the hungarian author poet and
translator george see itís he now lives
in the UK and writes regularly for a
variety of publications and lastly I'm
very pleased to welcome Daniel
domscheit-berg to the program he is a
German internet activist former
spokesperson for WikiLeaks and author of
inside WikiLeaks my time with Julian
Assange at the world's most dangerous
website well gentlemen given that all of
our agenda stories this week do involve
intial abuses of information media I'd
like to briefly ask all of you to give
me your take on the NSA scandal when you
look at what's been happening do you did
say to yourself well this was inevitable
in the age of Internet and electronic
media and basically we just have to get
used to it or do you see it as an
outrage that needs to be corrected well
I think that privacy has been
disappearing in the last decades and we
are citizens we have to regain the
privacy and the privacy of our data how
about you George Theotis I think we live
in an age of translucency so I think we
prefer to have control of our
transparencies the question is how we
define those areas and how we put those
definitions into practice Daniel
domscheit-berg the transparent
translucent person just an inevitability
at this point well I think actually that
what we see is a machine that has
developed into something that is not
accountable anymore that is not
controlled by any independent body and
it's very important that we are having
this debate which is long overdue so
it's not a question about if it's
invertible or not it's a question of
what our take on this will be as a
society so that snap poll of our guests
actually pretty much mirrors reaction
here this week Germans who are always
sensitive when it comes to abusive
privacy rights we're outraged to learn
that the US NSA is monitoring its
friends nearly as intensively as its
foes with the United States still trying
to maintain that there is a distinction
between espionage and information
gathering Europeans are demanding an
explanation and action it shouldn't have
come as a surprise just weeks ago NSA
whistleblower Edward Snowden revealed
that the u.s. was indiscriminately
spying on US citizens the NSA
specifically targets the communications
of everyone it ingests them by default
it collects them in its system and it
filters them and it analyzes them and it
measures them and it stores them for
periods of time documents leaked by
Snowden to the German magazine Der
Spiegel accused the u.s. of trying to
hack EU phone and email systems
both in the US and Brussels European
politicians have reacted with outrage
calling the US intelligence community
out of control French president Francois
Hollande has gone as far as to say that
if the allegations are true this could
derail a us-eu free trade agreement
Daniel domscheit-berg the reaction of US
officials so far has been more or less
well you know everybody's doing it just
yesterday we heard Secretary of State
Kerry saying look it's not unusual to
collect some information on your friends
there's a point to that isn't there well
first of all I think just because
everybody might be making a mistake in
one form or another it doesn't make this
mistake any better so that's I think
where we have to start on the other hand
there's a clear distinction in between
what the US is doing or even also the UK
is doing compared to what other states
are doing it's happening on a much wider
scope it's on an unhistorical e
unprecedented depth at which people are
gathering data and we certainly need to
talk about this isn't that mostly simply
because the US has the means to do this
this has got to be pretty expensive this
massive massive data collection program
basically there's no other country they
could do it and I suppose other
countries might be a little envious well
we've heard from the German secret
service the BND that they actually want
to have a bigger budget so they can
entertain similar kind of activities but
on the other hand you're right the NSA
is one of the biggest agencies in this
world they have funding that's much
bigger than any other comparable
comparable organization but that again
doesn't make it any better we have to be
actually very much suspicious about the
NSA actually because it is this big
organization and as such it holds much
more power than everybody else and
whoever wields that much power needs to
be held accountable by independent
bodies that are controlling such
organizations now the US of course says
that is the case there is a Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Court which
has to okay any attempt to look more
closely at the data they've made a very
clear clear distinction so far in the
u.s. between
ding metadata namely telephone numbers
and so on and actually targeting the
communications of a particular person
and the fact is Daniel domscheit-berg
they're not reading my mails they might
be reading yours but they're not reading
the male's of single citizens who
haven't so to speak put themselves in
harm's way are they that's not entirely
true either they might not be reading it
but what they do is that they're storing
it and you will never know if tomorrow
there is a reason for why they would be
interested in your emails and especially
here in Germany where we have in
historical legacy with the east of
Germany we can see that most people work
in further Stasi for example have been
extorted into that position as an
informer everybody has something that
they will be ashamed of that they have
to hide something that is so private
that would actually enable somebody else
if they knew about it to extort him into
to extort these people into something
particular and this is what we have to
understand there will always be a
particular piece of information that can
be used against you and it's just a
matter of if you're relevant enough for
that or not other governments have at
any rate definitely profited from the
u.s. programs we heard the Chancellor
herself say as much when Barack Obama
was here doesn't that make these
righteous protests perhaps a bit
disingenuous if not downright
hypocritical well I've in the last few
weeks actually spoken to multiple people
that have made this claim and I'm still
lacking evidence for any of these claims
and I can tell you that even within the
German government we have oversight
bodies that are controlling such
activities and even these bodies have
not heard of a single instance where
there's a clear connection between data
that was surveilled between data that
was stored intercepted somewhere and a
terrorist act for example that could be
prevented all you get is a headline to
such attacks were mentioned one was the
Sauerland a region in Germany where
there was apparently a ring of
terrorists who had an attack in mind
secondly the potential attack on the
German on the main train station here in
Berlin that was foiled you deny that
those were prevented but what I'm saying
is that all they say all they claim is
that something was prevented but not
even the government governmental body in
Germany that oversees these types of
activities has any kind of proof that
there is a correlation a direct
correlation between the information that
was gathered and the prevention of these
attacks and this is where I actually
would like to see more transparency
because we're not speaking about a
margin and a topic here but we're
speaking about something that is
affecting every private person every
business every every government and that
just doesn't stop anywhere but frankly
if you want these programs to be
effective they have to be secret if they
were to be brought into the light to the
degree you claim they couldn't be
effective anymore well i'm pretty sure
that there is a certain level of
accountability that we could establish
without rendering all of these very
potentially useful services completely
useless so I think there's there's more
leverage there than what people are
speaking about I would ask in just a
second how you might get more leverage
to change things but let me first open
it up to our other guests as well we all
talked about the idea that we are
increasingly translucent a moment ago
what are you all doing to protect your
privacy do you actually take measures or
you just kind of resigned well the
problem is you said before that nobody
was reading your email but actually
computers are reading your email and
European profile so if you write certain
keywords in your emails then some
computer program will store that
information and if you don't have an
insurance policy then you are a
candidate for being a terrorist so a lot
of that has commercial uses shouldn't we
perhaps be more concerned about
commercial abuses than what we're seeing
here is concerned about commercial
abuses but also about political abuses
and special in Germany in Germany there
is there was a tradition of collecting
all this data until nineteen forty-five
that was useful for the political
purpose that we know about so we cannot
be sure what will be the purpose in the
future for all these data George Souris
do you take extra measures to somehow
maintain sphere of privacy or you just
resigned not
totally resigned i think i would expect
quite a lot of what I put out in the
internet to be read to be turned to some
sort of use and one is always making
gradual and fine distinctions and that's
a problem because technology moves ahead
very very fast and be constantly having
tea really adjust our own standards and
our own desires to be private quite a
lot of us don't actually we want to
share ourselves to something that's what
people do in social media and Twitter
and Facebook so we have that in a kind
of desire and it's always a kind of
chasing after a disappearing bus really
to try and work out where is it you want
it to stop clearly a system which is
storing up potentially useful
information on you for all kinds of
purposes that you cannot tell which
requires some kind of regulatory body
the question is what how transparent is
a regulatory body at what level do we
need to try to make the kind of changes
that you Daniel domscheit-berg have have
said need to happen do we need an
international treaty would it be
effective or can we really hope to
effect change by putting pressure on an
individual government like the u.s. well
I think first of all what we need is a
widely lead debate and this is where I'm
hopeful that right now on this we have
to understand this is not the first
revelation about the NSA of this
particular type we had former NSA
whistleblowers that have by various
means try to expose similar things that
were developed we had Russell ties for
example that was trying to tell Congress
about this and he could not because
members of of Congress were not allowed
to listen to this kind of classified
information so we're we're hitting
limits within even the governmental
system that are not acceptable and we as
a let me just ask you something do you
suggest that if Edward Snowden had
followed the normal path of recourse and
for instance contacted his senator or
congressman and said look I've found
things that I consider to be Grievous
abuses of the Constitution that he
wouldn't have gotten any hearing no none
at all and they were
multiple multiple occasions in the past
where NSA whistleblowers have tried to
speak out and they were not even allowed
to and and that's a problem of
transparency and we we cannot we cannot
live in the world where not even the
government has controlled about what
other other governmental bodies are
doing this just doesn't work let me ask
all of you what you think should happen
to a whistleblower like Edward Snowden
polls in the u.s. show that people do
believe he acted in the public interest
and that he has sparked an important
debate but they also suggest that people
feel he ought to have stayed and faced
the music as we say what do you think
America he acted in a social responsible
manner because he saw that the US
Constitution was being abused and if you
if you see that the laws are not being
forward you have to act in consequence
and he had just a call his his senator
and then I assume he would be by now in
jail so the only the only way he could
bring this into the open person but it
was by being a whistleblower but George
theater should he then stay in the US
and have stayed in the US and face the
consequences given that this was an
active principle severe civil
disobedience literature suggests yes it
depends what he anticipates and I think
whistle blows are vital in Britain we
fed whistleblowers honest conditions of
hospitals how certain hospitals have
operated these whistleblowers were in
great danger in fact did lose their jobs
and couldn't find other jobs so do a
debate as daniel has said i think is
vital and also to have the debate as to
if somebody does blow a whistle on
something what are the procedures and do
we generally approve of those procedures
Daniel domscheit-berg one of the things
that this scandal has done is to
reinvigorate WikiLeaks it has been
helping mr. Snowden in his attempt to
find a place to take refuge what do you
make of that connection you of course
had quite a few problems with WikiLeaks
at the end well that's true on the other
hand
the organization i believe is at the
core at least still committed to this
whole idea so while there certainly is
some PR that's plain for wikileaks right
now on the other hand they are doing
what very few in the rest of the world
are stepping up for and this is to
engage to actively defend somebody that
has done one of the most tremendous
services to civil society that I'm aware
of in my life span this is one of the
most important publications and most of
the most important topics that was
raised for discussion and there's not a
single country here in Europe and we are
directly affected by this there is not a
single country that is stepping up and
that is saying that we're offering
protection and asylum to mr. Snowden
this is a shame it's an outrage and in
this respect whatever i agree with in
respect to to WikiLeaks they are
stepping up for him and they're trying
to help him so it cannot be as bad okay
thank you very what much well meanwhile
the EU council says that what's needed
in the case of Hungary is not more
surveillance but just some good scrutiny
so how solid is our democracy it's not
only civil rights activists in the US
have been posing that question but also
in Hungary constitutional changes
adopted there by the nationalist
government of President Viktor Orban
have sparked harsh criticism that it is
back sliding away from democracy the
government says it's taking measures to
respond but is it merely paying lip
service to EU concerns while the rest of
Europe is up in arms following
revelations that the US has been spying
on its European allies the hungarian
parliament has just passed a national
security law giving its government more
surveillance powers Prime Minister
Viktor Orban's approach has been called
Orwellian Borbon has changed the
country's constitution criminalized
homelessness and promoted nationalists
his critics say these crackdowns on the
courts and the media are part of a
larger bid to centralize power the EU
the US and the UN Human Rights
Commission have all expressed concerns
about the state of Hungary's democracy
the Council of Europe a human rights
watchdog has voted against putting
hungry under surveillance but it says it
still has serious and sustained concerns
about hungries commitment to democracy
George status how did you react to
hearing that the EU council has decided
not to put hungry on the list of
countries that it's monitoring not
altogether surprised because I think the
levels on which the I think counter
democratic processes continue in Hungary
are not done at that sort of level they
are done at that sort of level 2 but I
think most of the work is being done at
a civil and cultural level and is done
through funding it's turned through
financing or not financing of things
through recognition or non-recognition
of things the Constitution can be change
at the drop of a hat he has changed it I
mean their heads dropped four times
already when you look at that at what's
been happening to the Constitution do
you say well at this point it's hardly
worth the paper it's written on no I
think the Constitution's vital and I
think what the changes they have done
are potentially very dangerous the
report talked about media control and
quotes control the Hungarian government
and its supporters will say but look we
have a free press we got two or three
papers that freely criticize the
government with a radio that criticize
the government it's true but the media
laws have not been applied with any
great severity so far and the way in
which they have tried to put these lows
into operation has been through
exclusion non patronage the filling up
of prior of all important civil bodies
with their own representatives they're
cancelling of contracts the firing of
people all of these things are kind of
below the waterline you recently wrote
that hungry is on a fast
trackback to the past which past are you
worried that this is heading in the
direction of fascism for example yes I
do worry about it i don't think they're
there i won't want to accuse Viktor
Orban of being a fascist but I think
there are many signs at the Hungary that
he looks for is essentially centered in
the 1930s we have had the rehabilitation
of Admiral horty we are fed the
introduction of fascist and Nazi writers
on through school syllabus we are fed
the renaming of streets we have the
production of a whole mode of rhetoric a
whole mode of addressing the public
which i think is very much in sympathy
with the 30s is it really an ideological
kind of movement though or is it more
party and personality based I'm almost
thinking of putinism for example well
it's tempting isn't it and I think I
think or bands are very intelligent and
very clever man but i think that the
forces that he plays upon a crude forces
he uses them for whatever political ends
he has in mind in order to maintain his
hold on a public he has to pretend that
his government is the nation so whenever
somebody criticizes the government it is
immediately interpreted in attack upon
decent Hungarians Hungary as a nation
whereas it is only a vision of Hungary
well precisely but for exactly that
reason mr. just couldn't it be
problematic if the EU puts more pressure
on hungry isn't it quite possible that
that would simply provoke a backlash
that in fact people would feel more
defensive and there would be more
support for mr. Orban and and his party
I've seen this defense in an article in
The Guardian only a few days ago support
to the government saying if you're nasty
to us however more people will vote for
us or it's a very strange sort of
defense no I think they you have to do
it isn't there sure there is truth to it
but I think it has to be absurd it has
to be registered the problem is that
there's no united opposition against
them there's going to be an election
next year which I'm sure the government
will win but partly because the
opposition is broken
and partly because there are all kinds
of difficulties being put in a way of
that opposition being United as I say in
terms of cultural matters directors of
theatres whole academies are being
sidelined why is the opposition so weak
and do you ever take a look at what's
happening there and say you know maybe I
need to return and try to effect some
change well I'm not that important and I
put out but I think I'm kind of more
useful where I am because the difficulty
for them is getting out of these smaller
bits of news which are cumulative the
opposition is in pieces because of what
happened in 2006 when the then
government which was an ongoing
Socialist Party had a meeting behind
closed doors to its own members and in
which the prime minister then said we
lied morning in newnan light and night
everybody was lying about economic
circumstance and it was actually a key
to come clean but this closed conference
became public in 2006 there were riots
in the streets a day on on october
twenty third which is the anniversary of
the 1956 revolution the opposition at
that I mean the varieties were of
different varieties summer perfect
decent people complaining about this but
some varieties everything in Hungary
because of its history depends upon who
owns history who owns events who owns
1848 who owns 1956 the loans 1989
talking of 1989 that of course was the
moment when the East opened and in a
great flurry of optimism the EU of
course moved to incorporate Eastern
European countries into the union
looking back at that I wonder whether
our other two guests and you would say
we were too optimistic it was a mistake
if I look at what's happening right now
I see the Czech government involved in a
sex and bribery scandal Bulgaria facing
massive protests over corruption
Slovenia's economy in a very very bad
state
is democracy simply failing to take root
in the east well I think that democracy
is not something that happens overnight
so you need a period of transition you
need many decades of traditional
democratic tradition and the process we
are seeing now in Hungary or in Russia
or even in Arabic countries like Egypt
is that democracy is not a game of
winner takes all so if a party wins the
election that doesn't mean that this
party can just do everything the party
wants like putting their own people in
every single position they have to
respect the rights of minorities they
have to respect the rules of the
democratic game they have to respect the
media they have to give access to the
media to minorities so this what
democracy is a whole environment and
developing this environment is going to
take decades Daniel domscheit-berg how
do you see it well first of all you know
as long as I grew up I was told that
globalization is the thing that is
happening and it is what's happening
around the world so to me Europe is just
an intermediary kind of thing from my
state as being a German to developing
and to just being a human as everybody
else on this planet and in the meantime
I'm a European for now that's an
idealistic vision but are you satisfied
with where the eastern part of Europe is
heading I think actually the problem is
what what has just been mentioned the
problem is that there are that there are
structures that are trying to hinder or
that are trying to suppress this
development of people's ideas about what
the world is that they're living in it
is people that are still sticking to
nationalism to some to to patriotism to
to speaking about why their country is
so overall important or whatever and I
think in the end of at the end of the
day it all burns down to a lack of
communication it burns down to being too
much isolated from everybody else in
this if we can break that isolation if
we can foster free exchange between the
people then the European spirit is just
a natural consequence of that
communication and this is what we have
to look at and this is why freedom of
the press is so utmost important George
theaters that might argue for a more
evolutionary approach while
has also just said it takes time the
fact is the Hungarian government has
backed off on some of its measures after
the EU put pressure on it so are you
actually hopeful that that evolutionary
process that process of light pressure
can achieve results not in the next 10
years or so I don't think so i think
there is globalization and i think that
is why it is important that it you
should continue to watch what happens in
hungary hungary is an isolated country
in terms of language it has its own
peculiar history as do all the other
countries in that region and these
countries in that region are to some
degree attention with each other and I
always going to be attention because
partly of because of what happened after
First World War and the different
countries were split up and joined and
split again and there's no hunger in
very little time for democracy
historically really 1867 through to 19
19 while it's under Habsburgs and I
wouldn't call a period in between the
two wars precisely democracy it was a
kind of authoritarian state and it isn't
actually to be fur to the current regime
it isn't only them whose first instinct
is to try and silence the opposition it
has been instinct at every turn with
every government after 1989 so very
briefly if you would what is the EU need
to do now just keep watching just keep
watching keep watching okay thank you
very much well keep watching is exactly
what the robots in our next story are
doing a key element of the brave new
world of high-tech surveillance is the
flying robot known as a drone Germany
has just terminated a program to develop
military drones after media revealed
that the expensive machines were faulty
and prone to crash but the debate about
the merits of the technology and keeping
on watching continues drones have
changed the face of war the remote
technology offers military's a way to
reduce their own casualties and increase
effectiveness but critics say drones are
evil they lower the threshold make
killing too easy and
more collateral damage a group of
scientists and students at the free
university in Berlin are doing their bit
to give drones an image makeover enter
the good drone champion of the urban
battlefield whose only enemy is stormy
weather it's committed to delivering
your pizza on time and piping hot ok
relajada is this serious I'm going to be
getting my pizza in future from a drone
no not really so at the University we
have been developing robots for for many
different purposes for playing soccer
for autonomous cars for flying robots
that deliberate pits at the university
but it's very dangerous that it's
actually very dangerous son yeah I mean
after all these defects and crashes in
the German military program I'm not at
all sure I want these things flying over
my head even if it's only pizza that's
gonna fall on me well actually the rows
are flying everybody over your head
because if you see modern airplanes if
you see a Boeing Airplane Airbus
airplane they are like drones pilots and
don't don't have to do many things now
they just press the autopilot and then
the airplane goes they can even land
automatically so that means that and
that's the curse of my profession that
the curse of computer science every time
you develop something which is for a
useful purpose for for moving people
from one country to another then at some
point is to be there's going to be
someone who invents a way of using this
technology for war purposes and that's
the thing that worries me and I want to
ask you about that in just a minute how
you can separate those strands but first
of all tell us about the productive uses
tell us more about the kind of things
that the people in your program are
dreaming up besides pizza well of course
airplanes that can can fly people from
one country to another with a minimum of
pilots and with just one person who is
watching over their pain and it's
capable of repairing their opinion on
their or automatic delivery of route
from one country to another or automatic
ships or automatic cars that can take
you from your home to your work or can
become a part of public transportation
these are the kind of useful things that
we have been trying to develop as we
mentioned at the outset one common
thread in all of our stories this week
of course is surveillance information
what uses do you see in that area well
of course that's what has been making
the news and then in the last few weeks
or months the in the USA there is a lot
of interesting using drones for going
into Bobby your home and watching what
you are doing or four intersecting
telecommunications so and that's a
contradiction that I have to leave every
day so I'm interested in useful
applications peaceful applications of
technology but every piece of peaceful
technology can be transformed for
another purpose even the internet so we
saw it just a few minutes ago the
internet is a way of sending email is a
way of communicating is a way of
bringing people together it can be used
also for profiling people so let's take
a use like informational purposes that
journalists might want to have for
instance that they can maybe do some
kinds of research that weather was would
not be available to them are any of
these productive uses that you're
talking about so indispensable that we
must have drones to do them rather than
the tools we've already got now I don't
think so so I really think that at some
point you have to put limits the
technology we cannot remove people from
every single machine or from every
single productive application and the
problem is where do you draw the line
and where do we really want to remove
all pilots from the airplanes for
example that we really want to remove
drivers from cars or do we want to
remove all people from from the factory
if we can find all the kinds of jobs all
kinds of applications where they can
work and be productive and let's do it
but I think that technology should have
limits and in the case of Thrones for me
there is a clear line and surveillance
is not the kind of thing that I'm
interested but the question is once
you've got that technology out there
there's so much potential for it to run
away to escape control we're seeing that
with the NSA scandal and the end the
application of big data analysis and we
see it of course in so many other areas
now we've got these potential abuses of
privacy that drones bring with them and
then of course the military uses as well
when you look at all of that do you say
maybe we should just keep this
technology in the box maybe we shouldn't
be exploring it at all yeah there are
some kind of technologies that sure you
should keep in the box but that's not
really possible so that it's always
someone who's going to take it out of
the box and as I said before I think you
have a you have a nicer job that they
have because he's a poet and yes you
don't have to worry about the
technologies you are producing being
misused I have to worry about that every
day and that's really something I think
about a lot I saw both of our other
guests nodding when mr. hojas said that
it's simply not possible to keep things
in a box so George status when you look
at what's happening with these drones
and you hear some of those positive uses
out there do you look forward to a time
when maybe you could go out and hire a
drone to to do something important look
I don't have to do it I mean if I'm
going house hunting i go to Google
Street View yes and I can see the house
which I would like to buy not
interesting there was a kind of
agreement done with google street view
that when there were people you blurred
out their faces dr. Burke our numbers
you blew that the car numbers these are
always debates all you always have to
come back to say well what can you do
with this at what point do you want to
stop why did Google three to start
blurring faces it's because people
didn't want their faces included why did
they blur the car numbers because people
didn't
with the drones tooth it is this it is
really the same old story time and again
there's nothing I don't think in terms
of moral principles knew about the drone
unless you take it into the theater of
war in which case then you have a whole
lot of other questions to be asking but
in principle it's just another thing you
can do by pushing a button Daniel
domscheit-berg given that we can't
realistically easily keep technologies
in the box what kind of world do you
think we're going to be living in in 25
years one where little robots are
buzzing by our ears at every turn well
that's that's actually possible the
problem with these predictions is that
you can't even imagine the technological
world in three years so it's kind of
impossible to to come up with an with a
real concrete idea of what it will look
like but what's very clear I think is
that we as a society need to understand
that the world is going to increasingly
change and that that whatever regulation
or framework for regulation we have
today will not probably be applicable to
tomorrow or the day after that and that
all of this is a constant life cycle so
we have to re-evaluate constantly the
frameworks that we are putting up for
society and ask if they still apply or
if they need to be enhanced so that
nothing is running or developing into a
direction that we perceive as as bad and
that kind of technology certainly is a
is an example for this so Colin Cole has
quite realistically what might that kind
of a framework look like in your area
how could we try to put limits on the
bad uses and still allow potential for
those good Romans to be developed well
there's a lot of possibilities the first
thing is to start discussing these kind
of things that to make people conscious
about the misuse of technology and this
program is this this is just the
beginning the second the second point is
that we need some kind of loss or some
kind of international treaties where
this misuse is bad for example the use
of drones makes it easier to kill people
because you can just push the button
you'll kill someone in Yemen and then
you go have dinner with your kids that's
not that's
they humanizes even even war which is
which is the the least human occupation
that you can think of but robots can the
human eyes war and maybe like chemical
weapons were outlawed at some point for
war it should be it would be a good idea
to outlaw robots in the field of war
justice I see you nodding your head but
are you really optimistic that that's
going to happen the reason drones are
popular in the military of course is
that they save lives of soldiers yes
they do which is part of a kind of whole
moral conundrum because our ideas of
what are very old and they include
personal risk and they include some
sense of who it is you're fighting I
wanted to think back to a particular
example you know helicopters often film
traffic and about a few months ago an
Internet helicopter filmed a criminal
chase and guy went off and shot himself
that was shown on the television and
that was thought to be beyond the bounds
of what is permissible so there are
individual judgments that can be made
and you can draw general principles
probably from those individual judgments
Daniel domscheit-berg international
regulation it always sounds like
something that would be helpful and yet
getting to it is so very difficult
linking this story to the one about the
NSA do you see a real likelihood that
say 10-15 years from now we will
actually have treaty negotiations on any
of these issues that in fact are calling
out for international regulation I think
there's actually just really two
possibilities here so either we are
heading into a future that is not really
very bright from my perspective and it's
a future where we outsource
responsibility all the time and where
where we as a people don't care much
anymore or we remember what is something
that we increasingly tend to forget
which is that we as a people we are the
sovereign our governments our military
or whoever is there as an
governmental body they represent the
people of these cut the countries in
this world and of this world so if these
governments or organizations don't act
up in the way that the majority of the
people agree to then it has to be put to
a stop and this is what we kind of tend
to forget at least that's my impression
people feel so helpless towards the
government right now and I don't
understand why because we are the
sovereigns and not we are the ones that
put these people in charge and not the
other way around uncle house when you
look at the young scientists in your
Institute who are working on these
projects to what degree do you see in
them political concern about where this
might be headed or are they mostly
simply in love with the technology and
perhaps leave that aside no we try to we
try to discuss this with the students
and I think the students are very
conscious about this because there has
been a discussion for example in German
universities about the military use of
technology and some universities in
Germany like Bremen for example they
have a clause in the Constitution that
says that they are not going to develop
military technology so I think this
discussion has to be has the week press
Continue has to be alone every day and
we want our students to be not just
people producing technology but to be
people critical of technology certainly
Daniel domscheit-berg you have used the
Internet to try to get grassroots
movements online is that a potential
counterweight to what we're talking
about you say people feel they don't
have a voice do you see one developing
through those through those channels
that's actually what the internet
represents it is a voice where we are
peers among peers on the internet this
is what the inter internet protocol bias
basic aid based by specification gives
you it gives you a voice that is the
same voice that everybody else has that
is connected to this
tool and if we start using that voice
and if we start to organize and exchange
ourselves then there is a future that
looks brighter than what we're seeing
today optimistic last words thank you
very much to all of you for being with
us today that rounds out our agenda this
week don't forget you can watch the show
again online just go to our website DW
de english / agenda and let me know what
you think about the show it's been a
pleasure see you soon
what